Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and this week
on Game Of Thrones dying is thirsty work.
We got one of the best Arya Hound scenes I’ve
seen all season and a ton of really big moments
from the books.
Important announcement too, there’s no new
episode next week because of Memorial Day.
I’m also going to be traveling but I’ll
still do a bonus video.
If you’re finding me for the first time
be sure to subscribe to get it.
To all the regulars.
Round 7 of the giveaway starts now.
Remember all you have to do to participate
is be a subscriber and leave a comment on
this video.
I’ll just pick someone at random.
This episode made me so happy, so let’s
do top 5 moments and then my review.
Time to Fly, Careful for spoilers from the
episode if you haven’t seen it yet.
Here we got.
Number 5 - The Hound explains why he and Arya
are the same.
It was both heartbreaking and adorable watching
the Hound lick his wounds like a real dog.
But then he just breaks down emotionally in
front of Arya.
She had just done her big nothing is nothing
dark jedi in training speech so seeing her
be so genuine with him seemed a little strange.
I love the two of them together, they push
all the right fandom buttons.
But if she were really turning into a stone
cold killer, she wouldn’t feel sentiment
for the Hound.
She wouldn’t have offered to treat his wound.
Fire or no fire.
In case you didn’t remember, we learned
the Hounds story about the Mountain burning
his face during the tournament where they
fought.
Way way back when everyone was still alive.
I think someone was explaining it to Sansa.
I’m surprised given their similar family
upbringing that the Hound and Tyrion never
became friends.
Tyrion learned to deal with all the hate by
being witty, but it seems like the Hound just
turned everything inward and it became this
festering psychological wound.
Number 4 - Melisandre and Selyse
How surprised were you that Melisandre just
copped to perpetrating a lot of bullshit.
It seemed like 99 percent of her vials were
full of tricks.
But there was that one, the one you don’t
want to touch.
So it’s not all BS.
I wonder what’s in that one.
Also, we can’t escape that scene without
staring at the black hole that was her boobs.
I enjoy nudity on game of thrones as much
as the next pervert.
But were you surprised at how long the camera
lingered on her in the tub.
It’s like Melisandre was forcing Seylse
to look at her naked.
Like she has power over all flesh.
It’s hard to tell if Melisandre was trolling
her or not.
Because she dropped a huge bomb.
Remember how last season she talked about
the power in royal blood and the Gendry escaped.
I think they might be changing things from
the books and taking Shireen with them because
Melisandre wants to use her for something.
It’s not something that happens in the books.
But I’m really really curious to see where
they take that sub plot.
So don’t forget about Shireen, she just
got way more important.
Number 3 - Podrick and Brienne enjoy some
Hot Pie
I love Hot Pie so much, I’m so glad they
brought him back this early.
I actually just thought they were making a
subtle reference to Harrenhaal in season 2
and the Brotherhood in season 3 but they went
full on and he spilled his hot pie guts about
Arya.
You can tell he must be starved for conversation.
Or maybe he just talks that much with all
his customers.
I like the idea of a chatty Hot Pie baking
direwolf bread just enjoying his simple life
away from all the intrigue.
Like he’s the only character on the show
that gets a happy ending.
That would be hilarious.
But this whole situation was a huge win for
Podrick, because he’s the one that did the
Math and figured out the Hound would be taking
Arya to the Eyrie.
When they were at the crossroads, did anyone
else think that bandits would jump out and
stab them?
Anytime things get too quiet and characters
start looking around like they’re lost I
expect a sword to just materialize inside
their guts.
This is what happens when you watch too much
Game of Thrones.
Number 2 - Oberyn agrees to be Tyrion’s
Champion
The way they acted out that scene and the
music cues they used made it feel like a huge
battle had been won.
Like the end of episode 5 when Ghost came
back to Jon and you could just hear the whole
world cheering at the same time.
I loved Oberyn story about visiting Tyrion
at Casterly Rock when he was young.
That’s actually from the books.
One of several book moments in the episode.
There was even the shout out from when Cersei
almost yanked off Tyrion’s dick.
I wince every time I read that part.
Wow she’s horrible.
When is her reckoning coming?
If you didn’t see, Oberyn was actually crying
a little when he was talking about using Tyrion’s
trial to begin his quest for Justice.
The Mountain is just the first person on the
list.
It sounds like he plans on killing a lot of
people.
Not just Lannisters.
I appreciate the level of detail they went
to with how Cersei described Tyrion being
a monster.
Claws, Tail and a giant head.
and my number 1 WTF moment - Littlefinger
makes Lysa Fly
All of the Eyrie Sansa scenes were straight
out of the book, from the Snow Castle of Winterfell,
to the Littlefinger kiss to the Moon Door.
They really sped that plot up too, because
it’s from book 4 and back in King’s Landing
the trail is a book 3 thing.
I totally don’t mind, as creepy as Littlefinger
was with Sansa he gets a lot of the best speeches.
That should actually be a contest, see who
gives the best speech each season on Game
of Thrones.
Sansa is getting in deeper and deeper with
Littlefinger.
She had no idea what was going on with the
Purple Wedding plot, but this time she had
ringside seats for Lysa’s Murder.
And she is a really terrible liar.
Plus they have to deal with King Robyn.
As long as Littlefinger can keep the other
lords of the vale from taking over his stewardship,
Sansa will probably be okay.
Because Robyn is very Joffrey-Like in his
mood swings.
And the Moon Door is always going to be a
threat hanging over everyone’s head.
It’s like the ultimate prison sentence.
Like the Arryn’s can just push all their
problems into a nice little circular death
hole.
But now it’s your turn, let me know what
your favorite moment was.
And to all the book readers out there.
How do you feel about Arya being so nice to
the Hound?
That’s one change from the books that I’m
actually pretty happy about.
It seems like they’re making his character
much bigger than he was in the books, just
because those two work so well together on
screen.
Just so we don’t forget about Daenerys or
anything else going on, here’s a couple
things to keep track of.
First off, Daenerys is sending Daario to subdue
all the Wise Masters in Yunkai.
I loved that he was so restless.
He actually does have desires beyond Daenerys,
but yeah.
That look on her face made me laugh so hard.
Daario was already confirmed for season 5,
so he’s not going to die or anything.
But we’ll have to wait and see what happens
with the Wise Masters.
Then the other big thing is the defense of
Castle Black.
Alliser Thorne pretty much ignores Jon Snow’s
warning.
He and Sam are basically going to sit on top
of the Wall until that Wildling Raiding party
comes within eye shot.
But they will be able to see them coming.
So at least Jon will get that “I told you
so” moment.
Remember, Castle Black isn’t fortified from
the South.
I explained why in my bonus video from earlier
today.
I’ll have a link to that in the description
if you want to learn more about it.
Overall the episode was actually pretty happy.
I gave it an A minus just because I’m trying
to reserve A’s and A pluses for the best
one or two episodes of all ten this season.
It was really an episode of strong character
moments, yes Lysa flying through the Moon
Door was mostly a shocking moment.
But the rest of the episode was surprisingly
positive.
I couldn’t feel better about the Hound and
Arya, it’s like a few episodes ago she thought
he was the worst human being on the planet,
and now she’s taking care of him.
Even Jaime and Tyrion were acting like they
were little brothers trying to play a prank
on their dad.
Like they were two little boys just trying
to get a rise out of Tywin.
That look they shared, it was like they were
remembering their entire childhood.
I always love the way the show mixes these
really strong character moments with the oh
shit Moon Door scenes.
Even Littlefinger’s speech to Sansa was
really touching, about getting revenge for
Catelyn and the Red Wedding.
He kind of took back all that good will when
he kissed Sansa in that creepy way.
But for a minute his heart was in the right
place.
Let me know if there’s any big moments that
you think I left out.
Actually I just remember Lolly’s, it’s
funny and a bit dark when you remember what
happened to her that led to marrying her off
to Bronn.
Also remember, there’s no new episode next
week.
So I’ll be posting a bonus video instead.
Be sure to subscribe to get it.
My Q&A video will post tomorrow like normal.
Right now you can click here to get it.
I’ll add the annotation as soon as I post
it.
And click here to learn more about the Wildlings.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
High Fives!